well hundreds of thousands of federal
workers are set to miss their first
paychecks this Friday so Democrats in
Congress are working on a piecemeal
effort to reopen the government Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy what do
we expect from House Democrats now that
they do hold the majority well their
newest volley begins today and it's
going to continue over the next few days
what they're going to do is hold a
series of votes to essentially fund and
reopen these shuttered agencies one by
one so today they're going to kick it
off with the Treasury Department and the
IRS so that refund checks can continue
unabated and then tomorrow they'll vote
to fund the Interior and agriculture
departments so that food stamps and Farm
Aid can resume all of this however is a
largely symbolic move because the
republican-led Senate has said it's not
going to follow suit it is sticking with
the president what Democrats are trying
to do here however is try to put some
cracks in that Republican resolve peel
off Republicans who maybe either never
shared the president's passion for a
wall or who are concerned about the
impact of this shutdown in their
districts and Nancy we're starting to
see signs that certain Republican
senators are feeling that pressure from
constituents right right I mean all of
them are getting phone calls and you are
seeing some incremental change last
night Alaska Senator Lisa Murkowski
became the third Republican senator to
say publicly that we should reopen most
of these agencies as negotiations
continue here's what she had to say the
reality quote is that thousands of
furloughed federal employees and
contractors have no paycheck in sight
and there's no reason that they should
be held hostage to a political dispute
Republican leaders however continue to
say that Democrats need to get back to
the negotiating table with the president
and shouldn't be passing bills that they
know the president is not going to sign
Democrats say they've tried that that
the president's terms keep changing all
of the leaders are going to be going
back to the White House this afternoon
but as of right now nobody seems to hold
out any hope of a breakthrough all right
Nancy thank you
Lisa Murkowski be next the fifth
Republican to speak out like this in the
Senate if you add those five Republicans
to unanimous
Kratts you could pass through the Senate
what the House Democrats have put
forward it's just now
leader McConnell won't put that on the
those Republicans are up for reelection
as well at least some of them are some
are yes might be part of their
inspiration and they're certainly
feeling pressure it'll be interesting to
see how this all plays out it's really
hurting people it's really hurting
horrible a lot of people we paycheck to
paycheck